okay so here's the situation two sixty
symbols professors professor Moreau
field and Professor Moriarty both got in
touch saying they wanted to talk about
why the speed of light seemed to slow
down through glass essentially about
refraction so normally what would happen
I'd interview both of them do some
editing chop it all together and make
one video but we're going to do
something different this time I'm going
to show you both interviews pretty much
unedited except for a few little
cosmetic changes and cutting out a few
of my questions where you didn't really
need to hear my question I'm going to
let you watch them both this video is
Professor Moreau field and very shortly
you'll be able to watch the one from
Professor Moriarty
I want to do a video about refractive
index in because it actually has a
symbol apart from anything else but also
because it's something where we've done
quite a lot of videos which mention
refractive index and we talk about the
speed of light when it's going through a
medium through glass or something like
that and we talk about the speed of
light slowing down and invariably when
we do that there's this sort of
firestorm in the comments to the video
all about people say ah but photons
always travel at the speed of light
what's going on why does the speed of
light to slow down and so on so I wanted
to try and explain what's going on and
the fact that the speed of light really
does slow down when you're going to a
medium in crude terms if you measure the
speed of light in a vacuum you always
end up with the same answer three
hundred thousand kilometers per second
well they're about C okay if you measure
the speed of light in something else air
glass whatever it is you'll get an
answer the refractive index is just
defined as the ratio of those two
numbers so for example the refractive
index of glass is typically around 1.4
which means that light travels about 40
percent slower in glass than it does in
the vacuum that much yeah I always
imagined it was just like a miniscule
chair no so in air it's like it's you
know it's a fraction of a percent so air
really is the speed of light really is
very close to the speed of light but in
us in a fairly dense material like glass
yes it's about 40 percent slower in the
glass than it would be in a vacuum so I
mean it's responsible for all sorts of
things the reason why when you look
through glass you know when you look at
straw in a glass of water you see that
the straw appears to be bent and so on
so all these things to do with the pars
of light being bent are all to do with
what happens when light goes from one
refractive a medium with one refractive
index for a medium with another
refractive index so from for example
from air to glass or a hair to water
wear glasses I do so and you know they
wouldn't work if it weren't for
refractive index because that's what
bends the light right and so actually
yes lint the lenses wouldn't work so
lots and lots of physics really depends
on refractive indices so this always
comes out with people's a table well you
know so people are quite reasonably
happy with the idea of waves and maybe
the waves slow down but then you start
thinking about photons particles of
light and there's this view that a
photon always travels at the speed of
light and so when people start thinking
about this and say well how can it be
when you've got your photons going
through if you think of the photon
picture when you got your photons going
through glass why
that they take longer to come out the
other side so the picture a lot of
people have let me draw a picture for
you so the picture a lot of people have
is I've got a material rather than a
vacuum so I've got a lot of atoms in
there we atoms and make up and maybe
they'll be in a lattice if it's a solid
or they'll be randomly distributed if
its water or but there'll be just a
bunch of atoms so the picture a lot of
people have is my part of God light
comes in and kind of does a sort of
pinball pinball that's the what I was in
ok so so a picture a lot of people have
is that the light comes in and does it
sort of pinball thing of bouncing around
okay and then coming out the other side
and that sort of makes sense right
because the if this thing is still
traveling at the speed of light
obviously now it's travelled a longer
path to get out the other side and
therefore it should take longer to come
out the other side the problem with that
is if you think about it if take these
glasses make glass as an example where
you've got this refractive index of
around 1.4 that means that the path or
thing has to travel along has to be
something like instead of travelling
straight through it has to travel you
know forty percent further that means it
has to be sort of traveling on pause
like this right in order to come out the
other side for forty percent slower
because that's the angle that typically
you have to be going for this path to be
about forty percent longer than the
straight through path okay okay the
problem with that is that that would
mean that some of the light will do
there and some of the light will come in
and bounce this way and this way and
this way and this way and then end up
coming out that way so what you'd expect
for the light coming out the far side in
this case is that the light should all
be heading out in all sorts of different
directions just depending on what it has
to bounce off lost and of course there's
not what happens if you shine a laser
into a piece of glass then the laser
beam comes in one side and it comes out
the other side and it's still a laser
beam still all pointed in the same
direction so this picture really doesn't
work of thinking about this game of
pinball going on because if you start
doing that actually mean that the light
really should be spreading out in all
directions but couldn't I think of it
more as instead of pinball wading
through treacle or honey and I'm just
walking more slowly because it's harder
for my legs to move through this viscous
material but then you have to okay so
that's fine but then you have to get
okay so that's sort of a macroscopic
you know let's go down to the
microscopic view what's happening what's
the light doing when it interacts with
the atoms and there is another
possibility right the other possibility
that could be going on here's again
here's a bunch of atoms and it could be
that the lights coming in it's getting
absorbed by one of these atoms it then
sticks around for a little while until
all the atoms uses to reom it the light
again and send it on its way and that's
sort of at the microscopic level that's
this sort of what's going on in a treaty
picture that things are just being
delayed as they're going through again
there's a couple of problems with that I
mean we know that atoms do absorb atoms
on their own absorb light so this
picture sort of works that atoms do
absorb light and then they'll remit it
sometime later there's two problems with
that firstly atoms tend to absorb light
at very specific frequencies and so you
would then expect your refractive index
to affect those particular frequencies a
lot because the atoms are absorbing
light those particular frequencies and
other frequencies not very much at all
so that means that the refractive index
should vary dramatically depending on
exactly what wavelength of light you're
looking at it doesn't happen that way
refractive index does depend on the
wavelength of light but generally rather
smoothly rather than this very
definitive screen way the second problem
with that is that that is again
fundamentally a kind of a stochastic
process of random process how many atoms
did you happen to bump into in your way
through
how long did each atom happen to delay
the light for because how long a an atom
takes to when it absorbs a photon of
light how long it takes to remit it
again it's just a random process that
means that how long it takes a photon to
get through should just depend in a
fairly sort of random way sometimes
they'll get through very quickly
sometimes they'll have more a problem
again that's not what you find when you
measure that how you know you first turn
on a light through a block of glass and
measure when the first light comes out
the other side it's always the same
amount of time so again you can't have
any kind of stochastic process like that
going on all right then you've convinced
me that they're wrong
tell me what's right all right this is
where life starts getting very
complicated but yeah that wasn't
complicated enough this is where things
do start becoming a little more
complicated because now we have to start
thinking always with it with these
microscopic systems you can think about
them classically or you can think about
them in terms of quantum mechanics
and at some level they're sort of both
getting part of the picture it's just
like you know you can treat like
sometimes like a way sometimes like a
particle
so we need to think about both
possibility so let's start with the
classical end of things the wave end of
things what you've actually got in your
solid is a whole bunch of atoms arranged
in the lattice as the light comes in as
an electromagnetic wave okay it's
basically a varying electric field
that's going to jiggle all the atoms in
this thing because they've got charges
and so on so all the electrons are going
to get pulled around by that electric
field as it goes past and that's gonna
when you then start moving these
electric charges around that means that
each atom is going to respond by
producing electromagnetic waves of its
own okay so the waves come in they start
jiggling the atoms around which means
that each of the ways will then start
kind of oscillating in sympathy with the
wave that's causing it and it's the
superposition of the wave coming in
coming through the undisturbed wave and
all these sort of waves that are being
created by the atoms that make up the
material when you add all those waves
together you end up with the final the
wave that's actually propagating through
the glass and that wave is the one
that's then traveling at less than the
speed of light okay so even if each
individual wave that you're producing
could be traveling the speed of light
the kind of the superposition of them
then create something that's actually
sort of is 100 [ __ ] it hasn't
traveled quite as far as you expected it
to so the net effect of adding the light
that comes in with all light that you
end up generating through jiggling all
the individual atoms produces this
picture of a the overall wave that you
end up with by adding all that lot
together is traveling slower and the
problem is if you actually want to do
what you know I'm rather than just
sitting here waving your hands about if
I actually wanted to show you that
actually the speed that the net result
of adding all these waves together is to
produce a wave which is traveling at
less than the speed of light that's a
lot of maths and so you can do it by
solving the equations of what happens if
I had all these different waves together
each with different phase shifts and so
on but it's just a mathematical mess to
get to that point so when when Barry the
beam of light entered a piece of glass
and all and started making all the bits
of glass start jiggling how did that
then affect Barry the beam of light
it didn't accept well some of berries
let energy was lost because actually it
was being used to jiggle all these other
things around so some of that light
would have been lost for that reason but
it was then all these friends that Barry
had created in the process and the sum
of all those different waves then
created the net effect the net wave that
was traveling through the thing which
was that they no wave which was
traveling at less than the speed of
light what is it about all those friends
all that extra wave mnestheus
some don to bury that [ __ ] him
rather than enhancing him and making him
faster in fact you can in very peculiar
circumstances create things where you
end up with a wave which is traveling
faster than the speed of light in vacuum
physicists tend to try and keep quiet
about this because it makes life
complicated and it turns out actually
you don't end up you know everyone gets
worried because at that point you end up
saying am i breaking laws of physics and
my braking relativity and so on actually
you don't because then you start saying
okay so can I actually travel to
transfer any information through this
medium can I use this to actually get
information to travel faster than speed
like the answer is you can't because
there's two types of speed for a wave
there's a things called its phase speed
which is what I say I've been talking up
to up till now about there's also a
thing called its group speed and the
group speed is if for example you wanted
to produce a little pulse of light how
fast would that pulse propagate through
and the group speed and that's what you
need if you actually wanted to send
information because if I want to do
Morse code or whatever I've got to send
little pulses of light through it the
group speed always ends up less than
speed of light the phase speed under
peculiar circumstances can end up faster
than speed of light rather than slow and
then there's be the light so that's the
classical explanation okay
the simplest version of the quantum
picture is to say actually it's kind of
the same thing because the weird thing
so photons have really weird properties
right for example if you do this
experiment of having two slits and you
shine light through it you end up
creating an interference pattern just
because the light that went through one
fit slit interferes with the light that
went through another slit so it's kind
of the same mastery story we're talking
about before that you actually end up
with like carrying traveling through
different parts interfering and
producing a new phenomenon but actually
if you think about things in terms of
photons even if you have a light source
which is so weak that only one photon is
going through at a time you still create
an interference pattern and the only way
we can understand
there is if the photon actually went
through both slits so one particle
manages to go through both slits at once
and that's is this is getting us into
this weird quantum mechanical world okay
we can do the same thing with our solid
of saying okay so if I think of my light
as a bunch of photons I can actually
think of a photon following every
possible path through this thing and as
it goes through it interacts with each
of the individual atoms get sri radiated
and what i see in the kind of the final
light that this is producing is the the
superposition of all those things the
superposition of the light the photon
that came in undisturbed but also all
these other paths that it followed
interacting with all the atoms on the
way through and that really is basically
the same as the classical picture where
we've kind of each atom is sort of
producing its own version of the light
here it's just thinking about the photon
following every possible path and then
those photons that photon by following
every possible path ends up interfering
with itself and creating a net effect of
light that's traveling slower than the
speed of light where do you draw the
line though if this if our photon is
going through every possible way and we
add up the superposition every possible
way seems like an infinite thing it
could have it is yes it's very clever
how our photon manages to follow every
possible path to get to where it's going
nonetheless that seems to be when you do
the mass of say what would I expect to
see if that's the way that photons were
behaving and then look at the real
universe you find actually that's the
way the real universe works
I understand you gave to two scenarios
that is classical one helped you know
the jiggling and the adding of the waves
and that and this quantum one which is a
bit more mind-bending but nevertheless
the maths works the maths works for both
of them
except that which one is actually happy
but so that's the problem with physics
right is that physics what we're doing
is we're modeling reality there's one
reality you can have multiple models and
sometimes the models are exactly all you
know as far as we can tell there's no
you know the models are entirely right
in other cases each mole kind of
captures some aspect of reality in this
case you can sort of explain the whole
thing in terms of the quantum model
there are things you can't explain in
the classical model so in that sense the
quantum model is more
but actually the classical model is very
helpful because it's much easier to
picture and actually you don't end up
with these mind-bending things of one
photon following an infinite number of
possible paths and those kinds of things
so actually a lot of the time it makes
sense to think about things in terms of
classical physics just because it's
soluble we can understand what's going
on we have a physical intuition for
what's going on but once in a while you
have to delve into the quantum
mechanical explanation for things just
the messed things up still further
there's another quantum way of looking
at this which is this and again it's
this question of coming up with ways of
modeling things so I'll just talk about
two ways of modeling things there's
another way of modeling things that says
actually a system that's a kind of a
lattice or whatever that's in your your
material and the light traveling through
it is completely different from just
light in a vacuum and so actually we
shouldn't just think of you know light
in a vacuum we can explain as a photon
this combination of light plus the
lattice and all the way that the lattice
can be made to jiggle is a completely
different system and when we come to
solve that completely different system
maybe we'll come up with a completely
different particle rather than a photon
as the as the particle that's associated
with light and so physicists who study
these systems have actually come up with
a different way of mathematically
formulating these things where there is
a different kind of particle or thing
called a polariton and a pallet on is
it's this complex combination of the
oscillations of the electromagnetic
waves of the light and the oscillations
of all the stuff in the material it's
passing through
combined together produce this kind of
particle this kind of particle the play
written has mass and because it has mass
that means it travels it's less than the
speed of light so if you want a
different way of thinking these things
but also quantum mechanical one is that
your photon comes along when it enters
this medium the maths that you're
solving changes and so actually the
particle changes and instead of being a
photon it becomes one of these things a
polariton the peloton bimbel's along a
bit less than the speed of light and of
course when it comes out the other side
then once again you're solving the
regular equations of light in a vacuum
or light in air and that means that you
can then treat it as a photon again and
it scoots off at the speed of light
again
I told you the physics sleep yeah
everything's your fault
so if you'd like to see the Professor
Moriarty interview that will be
available soon unless you're watching in
the future in which case it's available
now links in all the usual places